CBS News chief White House correspondent
major Garrett has reported on president
Trump Supreme Court strategy since the
presidential campaign his new book takes
us inside the Trump White House I love
the title it's called mr. Trump's wild
ride the thrills and chills the screams
and occasional blackouts of an
extraordinary presidency major joins us
at the table to discuss good morning to
you major good morning you write a book
you don't have to wear a tie no promise
that's my rule I thought North said it
best when she walked in the green room
and said when do you have time to write
a book well look lots of Americans are
busy I'm just one busy American I wrote
of the night and morning but you know
folks have three jobs they're single
parents they work much harder than I do
so I wrote a book on the side and here
it is and here it is do you mind if I
start with the reading from the book not
at all go okay page 20 yeah because
you've covered many presidents major
Garrett you have and you write about
covering this one to be in the middle of
it day in day out felt like what I
imagined it would be to witness Cirque
de Soleil on acid so I think that's
descriptive enough I think that's very
discriminating
whatever grabber that's true you covered
ten different issues of the Trump
residence evening where he's gotten a
lot done the Trump presidency is real it
affects us emotionally it affects us
constitutionally it challenges our
institutions it's a constant topic of
conversation and amid all the cyclonic
spasms another phrase I use in the book
things are getting done everything he
wants to get done no but there are
things that this Trump presidency is
already accomplished or done depending
on your point of view that will be with
this country 5 10 20 years from now and
I already identified a few of them
because they're gonna be here well not
only tax cuts but cig most significantly
some say is the record he will have on
the courts not only the appellate courts
but also the supreme court already % of
this drama was Brett Kavanaugh is
related to what did and didn't happen in
the campaign year of 2015 and 2016 win
Senate Republicans didn't fill the
vacancy on the Supreme Court and I
explain exactly what Mitch McConnell's
calculations were on that how then
candidate Trump created a list of
potential Supreme Court nominees the
adhesive nature that had within the
context of Republicans voting for him
and the fury Democrats have about that
procedural action not to fill that
Supreme Court seat so when Republicans
now say well Democrats you know you
should follow process they're like
forget that yeah you didn't follow it
and this is your payback
all of that is in their adhesive what
you mean is that a lot of Republicans
voted for Donald Trump because they knew
he'd be able to do exactly when he's 10
they took that over all their other
reservations the only kind of
tit-for-tat major feels a little bit
like that and that's what the court
drama has been in a political context in
the Senate over the last 20 days on your
reporting what is the White House doing
to try and save Brett Kavanaugh they
know the president has limited political
capital right now and very little moral
authority they're relying on the Senate
Republicans and taking a break trying to
give some space to breathe on this
everything flipped yesterday sunday was
not the day when the White House said
you know what we need a public hearing
but within 24 hours the ground shifted
beneath them and they're now doing this
sort of a rearguard action to get some
time in space have this public
presentation and then vote as rapidly as
possible he's all the votes if they can
is there any evidence they've got a long
list they've got people on the on-deck
circle is there any evidence that they
are thinking of not backing their
nominee not yet but this intervening
period between now and Monday they're
going to be pushing back they're going
to be lifting up and they're gonna see
what the politics lands alright we're
gonna have to leave it there major
Garrett okay mr. Trump's Wild Ride
thanks for being here thank you for
having me it's on sale today by the way
yeah just to throw that in yes it's on
sale today